all right so that's just for say that
okay good good good me get out there
sorry y'all want to do some of that gaga
No who's this guy y'all never heard of
the gods wrong well I've never heard of
that AKA slayer cutty cutty
double cutty elmo cat vag long island
brain slice Funt fun font font i figure
that it takes all your greatest fears
and insecurities and it gives them teeth
in arms and then it locks you in the
room with them from which you cannot
escape
well that sounds terrible you realize
the face of God is somewhere inside your
body but you can't find it
okay none of us are interested in this
drug thank you sir nice to meet you
it's a razor-sharp crystal you tuck
under your eyelid and then when your
ocular cavity starts bleeding it goes
directly into your brain well there's
got to be a good part yeah you've just
described a life wrecking physical
addiction but when you'd let him finish
if you let him finish he's gonna get to
the euphoria I'm sure this would you you
poop your mouth I'm sorry what you
pooping your mouth no you poop out of
your mouth I'm in dude Capcom Adam dude
guys if people really go through this
the hi must be amazing buddy another one
you did mushrooms and you cried for
three hours Oh
I know I don't do drugs drugs are for
losers
[Music]
you